[Música]
diplomacia para intentar solucionar la
crisis fronteriza en ucrania ante la
presión militar de rusia el ministro de
exteriores ruso recomendó continuar las
negociaciones mientras que la onu pidió
reducir la especulación
ley de emergencias en canadá el primer
ministro georges team crudo invocó este
poder para enfrentar las protestas del
llamado convoy de la libertad se opone a
la vacunación contra el kobe 19 esto le
permitiría desplegar al ejército en las
calles
inició el juicio contra cuatro hombres
presuntamente implicados en el asesinato
del sacerdote francés jacques a mel el
murió degollado en 2016 en medio de un
ataque perpetrado por sus simpatizantes
el autoproclamado estado islámico los
autores materiales de los hechos
murieron tras el ataque a manos de la
policía
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy manejar a calle y es un placer
volverlos a saludar y comenzamos en
europa del este porque moscú y occidente
aún le apuestan a la diplomacia para
descargar las tensiones en la frontera
entre rusia y ucrania hoy el ministro de
relaciones exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov le recomendó al mandatario
vladimir putin continuar las
negociaciones pues afirmó que hay
posibilidad de lograr un acuerdo sobre
la seguridad mientras que el mandatario
ucraniano volodymyr selenski le pidió a
quienes han abandonado a su país que
regresen justo el mismo día que eeuu
clausuró su embajada en kiev para mover
sus operaciones a la ciudad de leópolis
más cerca a polonia por su parte del
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres se mostró preocupado por lo que
llamó la especulación
y estoy profundamente preocupado por el
aumento de las tensiones y el aumento de
la especulación sobre un posible
conflicto militar en europa el precio es
sufrimiento humano destrucción y daño a
la seguridad europea y mundial es
demasiado alto para contemplarlo
security es tú a tú con templates
vending diplomas y for confrontation es
no abandonar la diplomacia por la
confrontación no es cruzar una línea es
lanzarse al precipicio en resumen mi
llamado es este no fracasar la causa de
la paz tú no te fails
otra de las movidas diplomáticas para
intentar desescalar las tensiones entre
rusia y occidente fue la visita del
canciller alemán olaf scholz a kiev allí
se reunió con el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski y adoptó un tono más
fuerte contra el kremlin advirtiéndole
que cualquier agresión tendría graves
consecuencias scholtz viajará mañana a
rusia para avanzar en la diplomacia
un desfile de diplomáticos con el
característico apretón de manos que
busca evitar lo peor
olaf scholz es el último líder europeo
en dirigirse tanto a ucrania como rusia
en un intento de calmar las tensiones
poco después de aterrizar en kiev el
canciller alemán reiteró su apoyo a su
homólogo ucraniano volodymyr selenski y
expresó a moscú sus exigencias de imagen
que no hay más vuelvo dejar claro a
quien quiera que la soberanía y la
integridad territorial de ucrania no son
negociables para alemania por tanto
esperamos que rusia dé pasos claros para
escalar las tensiones actuales
y es que la acción de game that in spain
scholz sigue los pasos del presidente
francés emmanuel ma crono mientras los
líderes europeos se unen tras el temor a
una inminente invasión de ucrania rusia
ha acumulado más de 130.000 soldados en
la frontera del país y las fuerzas de la
otan están preparando su respuesta a ese
poderío militar con una expedición de
soldados alemanes que aterrizó en
lituania el lunes y el envío de más
aviones de combate f-15 a polonia por
parte de eeuu
reino unido también está dispuesto a
aumentar sus tropas de la otan en
estonia aunque el primer ministro boris
johnson dijo que todavía espera que se
pueda evitar el conflicto
esta es una situación muy muy peligrosa
y difícil estamos al borde del
precipicio pero aún hay tiempo para que
el presidente putin dé un paso atrás y
lo que pedimos es que todos dialoguen
una propuesta también se está
considerando en moscú según una reunión
televisada entre vladimir putin y
sérguei lávrov el ministro de exteriores
ruso dijo que todavía hay una
posibilidad de resolución diplomática
con occidente y nuestras opciones están
lejos de agotarse pero las
conversaciones no deben continuar
indefinidamente pero en este momento yo
sugeriría que continuaremos las
conversaciones y les ampliaremos
moscú sostiene que no tiene planes de
invadir ucrania a pesar de la
preocupación internacional sin embargo
en lo que respecta a la diplomacia
muchos siguen temiendo que las
conversaciones fracasen en un tema clave
el ingreso de ucrania a la otan es al
que rusia se opone rotundamente
ley de emergencias en canadá el primer
ministro jostin trudeau advirtió que
durará 30 días y que se aplicará en
ciertas provincias
el mandatario invocó hoy ese poder para
hacerle frente a las manifestaciones de
los transportistas la declaración le
permitiría al gobierno federal desplegar
al ejército aunque todavía falta que el
parlamento apruebe la medida manuel acá
no nos cuenta más
el gobierno federal ha invocado la ley
de emergencias para completar la
capacidad provincial y territorial para
abordar los bloqueos y las ocupaciones
esta decisión de entra en vigor y con
ella el gobierno tendrá medidas
temporales especiales para garantizar la
seguridad nacional durante 30 días
una decisión con la que el primer
ministro yo sin trudeau buscará hacerle
frente a los bloqueos y protestas que se
han presentado en el país a raíz del
llamado convoy de la libertad
la ley de emergencia será usada para
fortalecer y apoyar a las fuerzas del
orden en todo nivel a lo largo del país
es para proteger la seguridad de los
canadienses proteger los empleos y
restaurar la confianza en nuestras
instituciones
la ley de emergencias de 1988 ha sido
pocas veces invocada en el país es la
segunda vez que se activa en tiempos de
paz fue el padre del mandatario pierre
elliott trudeau quien activó su versión
anterior en 1970 la aplicación de la
medida debe estar justificada por una
situación crítica y urgente que pone en
peligro las vidas la salud o la
seguridad de los canadienses y permite
incluso el traslado de los militares a
las calles del país las protestas ya
hicieron eco en la provincia de ontario
este fin de semana recibir
recomendaciones del doctor mor sobre un
plan para reabrir nuestra economía y
abandonar el sistema de pasaporte de
vacunas en ontario studies randers jones
a pesar de que el puente ambassador que
comunica a canadá con su vecino ya fue
despejado los reclamos no cesan en
diferentes partes del país
inicio en país el juicio contra cuatro
presuntos cómplices del asesinato de un
sacerdote francés llamado jack am él
hace seis años dos asaltantes lo
atacaron y lo degollaron mientras
celebraba una misa en una pequeña
localidad de normandía les contamos más
en este informe
fue un ataque que conmocionó a francia y
al mundo entero días después de
conocerse por internet dos asaltantes de
19 años se unieron para atacar y matar a
un sacerdote de 85 años el padre ya
camel fue degollado mientras impartía
una misa en su iglesia del noroeste de
francia los autores de los hechos ya
estaban bajo sospecha y vigilancia de la
policía uno de ellos llevaba incluso una
pulsera electrónica después de que las
autoridades descubrieran que intentaba
viajar a siria pero ambos consiguieron
eludir la vigilancia tras asesinar al
sacerdote los atacantes murieron cuando
intentaban salir de la iglesia
seis años después comienza en parís el
juicio contra tres presuntos cómplices
de todo un atentado no es sólo algo que
ocurre en un momento dado está lo que
ocurre antes y después antes de un
atentado hay personas que aportan los
medios que alientan el atentado un éxito
los tres hombres que según los fiscales
conocían el plan son acusados por
participar en una conspiración criminal
terrorista como defensa sus abogados
aseguran que son chivos expiatorios un
cuarto hombre será juzgado en ausencia
se cree que rachid qásim murió en un
ataque con drones cerca de mosúl hace
cinco años y se le acusa de haber
elegido el objetivo haber aconsejado y
animado a los atacantes es un
propagandista en telegram lavaba el
cerebro y convencía a los jóvenes
franceses para que actuaran en casa se
espera que el juicio dure cuatro semanas
por primera vez desde que es presidente
de turquía recep tayip erdogán visitó
emiratos árabes unidos- mientras que el
primer ministro de israel naftalí
bennett viajó a bahrein ambas reuniones
destacan las recientes estrategias de
acercamiento que están en marcha en el
golfo donde está cambiando el ajedrez
político aquí les explicamos qué hay
detrás de la normalización de estas
relaciones que antes eran conflictivas
el informe lo tiene la ugel este lunes
dos visitas oficiales hicieron historia
en el golfo en bahrein el primer
ministro naftalí bennett se convirtió en
el primer dirigente israelí en realizar
una visita oficial en el pequeño estado
una etapa simbólica para israel que
continúa con su objetivo de fortalecer
sus lazos con algunos estados árabes
creo que especialmente en estos tiempos
tumultuosos es importante que desde esta
región enviamos un mensaje de buena
voluntad de cooperación de estar juntos
frente a los desafíos comunes y de
construir puentes hacia el futuro
y la normalización de las relaciones
entre los dos países empezó en 2020 tras
los acuerdos de abraham negociados por
eeuu
desafiando décadas de consenso árabe en
las que se descartaban los lazos en
ausencia de una solución al conflicto
palestino-israelí pero barren y israel
comparten ahora una preocupación común
por el programa nuclear de irán el mismo
día al presidente turco recep tayip
erdogán viajó a los emiratos árabes
unidos- la primera reunión entre los dos
antiguos rivales desde hace casi diez
años
el diálogo y la cooperación entre
turquía y los emiratos árabes unidos son
importantes para la paz y la estabilidad
de todas las regiones
no consideramos la seguridad y la
estabilidad de todos los países hermanos
de la región del golfo como algo
independiente de la nuestra
los dos países han mantenido una
relación tensa en los últimos años ya
que abu dhabi acusa a ankara de apoyar
el islam político en el medio oriente
pero en medio de un colapso económico en
turquía intenta ahora sanar sus
relaciones que en este caso se
materializa en la firma de acuerdos
estratégicos con los emiratos árabes
unidos- en varios sectores defensa
transporte tecnología y economía así que
en el golfo las prioridades y los
intereses comunes logran bajar al de
nuevo las cartas geopolíticas de la
región
el estado de karnataka en el sur de
india reabrió algunas de sus escuelas
que cerró luego de las protestas de la
semana pasada por las estudiantes que no
podían usar jeeps ni burkas en clase las
autoridades prohibieron las reuniones de
más de cinco personas en un radio de 200
metros alrededor de las instituciones
educativas ahora que comenzaron las
clases de primaria y secundaria aunque
los grados superiores y las
universidades siguen cerrados esta
decisión se produce cuando el partido
del primer ministro narendra modi se
prepara para las elecciones en estados
clave
al menos dos personas perdieron la vida
en medio de una nueva jornada de
protestas contra el golpe de estado
según denunció el comité central de
médicos sudaneses estos hechos
ocurrieron en jartúm la capital de sudán
en la ciudad vecina de um durman donde
las fuerzas de seguridad reprimieron las
movilizaciones con lo ocurrido este
lunes aumenta a 81 el número de
manifestantes fallecidos durante las
marchas
cada 14 de febrero se celebra el día de
san valentín
esta es una festividad de origen
cristiano que recuerda las obras
realizadas por san valentín de roma en
relación al concepto del amor parejas en
diferentes países aprovechan esta
jornada para casarse sin embargo para
algunos no es más que una fecha
comercial veamos a continuación cómo ha
evolucionado esta festividad
ya sea en campos de refugiados o en
cascadas parcialmente congeladas
personas alrededor del mundo celebran
cada 14 de febrero el día de san
valentín conocido también como el día de
los enamorados aunque también está
relacionado con una fuente importante de
ingresos la federación nacional de
minoristas la asociación de comercio
minorista más grande del mundo espera
que el gasto este año alcance los 23 mil
900 millones de dólares mientras que en
colombia los exportadores de flores
esperan que las ventas superen los 1.730
millones de dólares del año pasado este
año tenemos un incremento del 35 por
ciento versus el primer año de pandemia
y un incremento del 25 por ciento versus
el año anterior al primer año de
pandemia marcado porque porque la gente
cada día hace más trabajo en oficina en
todos los países a los que exportamos y
la gente quiere ver su casa bonita
entonces se ha incrementado bastante el
consumo de flores
pero no todo es dinero en perú nicaragua
y sudáfrica a varios ciudadanos
aprovechan bodas masivas para consolidar
su amor en este día en serbia realizan
un concurso anual del beso más largo los
ganadores establecieron un nuevo récord
de 112 minutos sin embargo san valentín
es menos popular en algunos países
musulmanes como pakistán malasia arabia
saudita e indonesia donde los
estudiantes de un colegio musulmán
protestan en contra de este día ya que
denuncian que es una celebración
occidental que fomenta el sexo casual
según la experiencia cada día de san
valentín
los adolescentes tienen sexo libre beben
alcohol afortunadamente el organismo de
educación gubernamental ha instado y
apoyado la prohibición del día de san
valentín
entretanto en méxico casi un centenar de
mujeres aprovecho la víspera de esta
festividad para protestar en contra de
los feminicidios
y con esta nota sobre el día de san
valentín terminamos nuestra emisión
informativa los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con la señal de france 24 que
es 24 horas nos vemos
[Música]